sportsmanship has
always been an important part of
competition
swapping jerseys or comforting your
opponent
after they lose helps display a mutual
respect
because even some of the world's
greatest athletes can't deny that their
rivals have only helped them become the
best
we have that battle the last 15 years
which is good
he pushed me and i push him as well but
sometimes being all
nice and respectful gets kinda boring
sometimes you quite literally dunk on
your opponent
and at that point you don't owe them
[ __ ]
and when you already know that you're
one of the world's best then
who cares the best player in the biggest
sport has to be
obviously the ultimate yeah that's what
i feel like
but having an ego isn't limited to
traditional sports
in fact we have seen our fair share of
bm
in esports how good is it to get a
pentakill at the lcs all-stars
lcs all-stars it technically was europe
versus north america
everyone else is trash right here on the
show everyone else is
trash oh this is free oh let me see this
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh tell him
tell him about himself tell him about
himself let him know him
tell him about himself
[Applause]
although verbal bm has become a bit more
tame over the years
there are still certain players who
can't help but
rub it in your face oh go
go god i love it yes cool how mad are
you right now
but one form of bm has stood the test of
time
teabagging regardless of what games
you've played over the years
chances are you've been a victim of the
old tactical crouch
at one point or another and in valoran's
brief history
no player has pissed off more rival
teams fans with their disrespectful
antics
than sentinel's white claw crushing
cipher main
michael dapper gullino
a talented troll who's helped his team
take over valerian for the past year
while adding a little bit of spice to
the game dapper can do this
celsius out the open the spectres win
the 2v4
what not again man zombs and dapper dude
do your dance do your dance yeah get it
dapper yes sir
yes sir i was like yeah
he's still going for more zach is going
to hold his angle and just trying to
trade guns out
with a 360 clip it again chat thank you
jbl in advance
no and dapper is looking to clutch up
again
he's uh he's just built different he
actually
is dapper has been insane in the clutch
in this series too
oh my god i'm telling you the
psychological factor dog
i mean she stops diffusing to shoot his
body so how exactly did dappers
rise to villainy begin and how has he
used his mind games
to not only make sentinels one of the
most polarizing teams invalorent
but literally the best in the world
spike's planet dapper toyin
here cipher diff cipher diff toy
oh no like i don't really respect you
bro like you have to beat me and i don't
give a [ __ ] who you are you know
like at the end of the day you're just a
player to me i really don't care who you
are
hey guys so before we dive into dapper's
spicy story i
gotta ask that you please please please
like the video subscribe to the channel
and teabag on notifications just so you
don't miss
any future offbeats i did not write that
just so you know alright so aside from
shooting his opponent's lifeless bodies
and dunking his digital
nut sack on them every chance he gets
who exactly
is sentinel's crispy 22 year old clutch
artist
well before he started beating hundred
thieves in his underwear and hitting the
gym with his teammates
he was like just about every valerant
player under the sun surprise surprise
dapper got into competitive gaming with
counter-strike i got into cs from my
cousin
i feel like it's such like a cliche like
storyline now that like you're your
older sibling or like your cousin
someone someone older than you kind of
brings you into the game
but yeah my cousin played 1.6 and i
never never got into 1.6 but like
i said play like when he got off when i
was over his house and stuff i went over
there a lot
but in 2004 when cs source came out
dapper truly found himself hooked as a
young
filthy casual he often played fun
community made modes with his friends
like jailbreak
bunny hopping death run and surfing but
before he even had a chance to
dabble in source's competitive playlists
a new game caught his eye i started
playing league of legends like season
two
like season three i like made all the
way to like i think i was like diamond
one cap or like
just hit challenger before there's like
masters or anything i like just hit
challenger
now as much as dapper loved playing
league of legends and even entertained
the idea of possibly going pro in it
he missed playing with his friends who
weren't really interested in playing
riot's moba
i mean can you blame them like so
when valve released their newest
iteration of counter-strike in 2012
dapper came crawling back and from there
he really started grinding the game so i
just started playing cs go a lot
a lot a lot just like i don't even think
i hit global i was like dmg and i
instantly got like eca
because i heard it was like better and
more competitive so i pretty much
i literally started from the ground up i
was like a nine-yard rws like
scrub in esa like way back then so yeah
uh
then from then on i was grounded through
the league so i really went like open
intermediate
maine premier and then pro as a
promising young player
dapper found himself hopping around
various up-and-coming rosters but he was
finding it difficult to break into the
tier one
scene but in april of 2020 he like so
many others in nacs
was presented with a new opportunity
valorent valorant came at the perfect
moment for dapper tier 2 nacs was
slowly withering away and with more and
more north american teams leaving the
scene
there were even fewer opportunities for
him so
like many other constituents of nacs
dapper's move to riot's new tactical
shooter
seemed inevitable but i was like one of
the last people to change during beta
like pretty much the last wave of beta
players that moved over cause i i really
like cs i i
i still enjoy the game i thought i had a
feature i was playing really i was
literally hitting i think i was like
peak form in cs when i left so i was
like dude i'm playing so well like do i
really want to like throw this all away
you know like there's opportunities out
there like if i really grind like
i really had like a lot of sleepless
nights thinking about it but at the end
of the day i was like
this is like guaranteed like i'll be
good in valerian and i could like make a
really big name for myself well cs
it's like there's an opportunity to do
that but
like wait maybe it's it's a risk you
might not ever get there like you might
just never get the opportunity for like
whatever reason it is
going all in on valorant dapper began
playing with together we are terrific
a lineup comprised of former cs players
like himself
and although dapper enjoyed moderate
success with the team
eventually he was dropped from the
roster but fortunately for dapper a
bigger opportunity was coming his way in
the form of a trial
with sentinels and then eventually
because i was playing cipher
and then sentinel's need a cipher they
had like their core four that were
signed but they were like trying out
fifths
uh shazam and sick knew me from cs they
knew i was really good they knew i was
like a young kid with passion i grinded
hard
so they gave me the opportunity to try
out and i guess they just liked me so
they signed me
though things were rocky in the
beginning sentinel's results actually
began to
improve with dapper in the lineup and
while he was clearly making a difference
as a player
it was how he carried himself on the
server that began catching everyone's
attention
tens with a second now it's just dizzy
in a 1v5 catches
oh 601 and dapper as a knife
the trades are looking phenomenal right
now from sentinels leaving it only just
down to the sage player of tsm
trying to see if he can connect the
sheriff not until
that's insane the 360.
there's a lot from finesse now his staff
is down to try to do some economy damage
let's see if he can find anything else
and the white people
now of course everyone can appreciate
that little bit of bm
that dapper was throwing into valerian's
competitive scene but it's safe to say
that there were those who weren't too
happy about the lack of respect he was
showing some of their favorite players
he even received a death threat from one
of these crazed fans in december of last
year and it wasn't
just fans who were rattled by dapper's
antics
even riot tried asking players to put an
end to all of this bm
and of course everyone thought that they
were being soft but the thing that makes
dapper such a compelling character
is that whether you love him or hate him
he
genuinely doesn't give a [ __ ] if
anything the backlash he's received from
his critics has only caused him to
ramp his behavior up just to piss
everyone off even more
and while it's true that dapper's
nut-dunking nonsense
may not be for everybody most of his
opponents
don't take it personally in fact most of
them understand that it's
just part of the game i mean i don't
really care i think it's cool
i mean as long as he's he's trying to
get his team hyped you know what i mean
so that gets his team hype that more
power to him but for dapper
it's not just about hyping up his team
no he knows that
deep down there's something about
teabagging and
shooting bodies that just
bothers people and engaging in this kind
of psychological warfare
might even be giving him and his roster
a competitive advantage
i just know for a fact some people just
get so pissed off about it
and like how i view it it's like if
they're getting pissed off or something
that like
i'm not spending money to do you know
not in game money i'm not
it's just a free advantage right there
just shoot their body teabag them they
get mad they play worse
some's holding on for dear life it's
masked his position
healed him a little bit but he might not
be expecting
sick to be rotating around they're just
holding him in that spot
but the thing about dapper is that he
isn't just some loudmouth troll who's
all talk no he has proven that time and
time again
that he has the play to back it up oh
that's brutal
great cam from dapper allows sick to
take out marv
through the dark cover
he checks it even though the drone it
seemed like the drone
kind of cleared it he still checks that
oh this guy if nothing you can't pull
the wall over his eyes somehow
hey 3v1 dapper needs to do something
crazy finds the kill onto one and here
comes the crazy
i want to grab a nine to three half as
the neural theft gives the info
that he needs dapper gonna look to push
on shock starting to find some damage 90
or 67 excuse me hp
one comes through almost zapper gets it
done 9-3 at the half
what a way to close it out from the
sentinels here
it's up to dapper there oh
whoa what the hell was that from dapper
and sure it's all well and good to clown
on people during
online events where the stakes and the
pressure
aren't particularly high but dapper and
sentinels
brought this mentality to valoran's
first major international event in
reykjavik iceland
showing that they're more than happy to
continue these shenanigans on the game's
biggest stage and yes he did confirm to
us
that tea bags do in fact hit different
on land yeah so the tea bag it's more
fluid
you just feel like you're kind of
immersed when you do it so it just makes
it feel ten times better
but most importantly for dapper
sentinels were able to prove that north
america
isn't entirely hopeless when it comes to
esports
while the region has historically fallen
short on the international stage
especially in games like counter-strike
and league he and his teammates are
willing to do whatever it takes to
change that narrative invalorant and by
cruising through the entire event
without dropping a
single map only to be crowned champions
it's hard to deny that they're doing
just that
yeah i mean it feels surreal i still i
don't think it'll hit me for a little
bit
you know just like that we actually
cemented ourselves on top of nine
international sport
like to me uh with no crowd
you know someone's telling me we have
like a million viewers it doesn't really
hit me like yeah this is the top like we
we did this we're the top the truth is
that every game needs a guy like dapper
who's just willing to get on people's
nerves and play the heel
his signature behavior is actually
helping to develop valoren's competitive
scene
ensuring that new rivalries and story
lines are created
such that future events are even more
compelling to watch
and until somebody finds a way to shut
down dapper and the rest of sentinels
then he's just gonna keep doing his
thing dumpstering his opponents and
rubbing it in their face on his game's
biggest stage
literally oh no no don't do it
oh look you managed to you put a bit of
a target on your back now
for every future valor event so dapper i
want to hear from you what you have to
say to the rest of the valent world out
there who's looking to come for you
you know good luck we're just going to
get better
sick yes
so clutch so how does it feel that na is
finally the best at an esport
and how many white claws are you going
to crush tonight you know i know it'll
feel great when we get back home
and with the white clock question i
don't even remember what time my flight
is but i'll probably miss it